[Musique]
l'eau de l'été enfin on espère qu'il va
se pointer et c'est l'aube de plaids
événement festif qui ont lieu un peu
partout à travers le pays auquel sont
invités les artistes canadiens québécois
et autochtone là est la question
les voit-on souvent sur les grandes
scènes est ce qu'on les les invite
automatiquement ou est-ce qu'il ya
encore des efforts pour que ces gens là
se retrouvent sur les grandes scènes
nous allons en discuter avec une artiste
qui sera là dans quelques instants
mais pour l'instant ils avaient picard
bonjourbonjour mathis harvey bonjour une
troisième éviter d'en kathia rock elle
sera là dans quelques instants on avait
annoncé aussi sa mian s'il annonce
amiens a décommandé il n'a pas pu venir
samyang qui se prépare d'ailleurs je
pense qu'il va donner un spectacle au
mois de septembre il sera avec
l'orchestré symphonique du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean et il avait
envie de venir évidemment parler de son
spectacle mais c'était un peu trop tôt
mais nous on a envie de parler plutôt de
sa place sur les grandes scènes et il ne
pouvait pas être là pour ça mais les
grandes scènes elles ne sont pas tant
occupé que ça par les autochtones on ne
les voit pas tant que ça je pense qu'il
ya des raisons historiques liées à ça et
on va commencer avec vous ils appellent
pour expliquer ses raisons historiques
oui oui en fait j'ai eu envie
aujourd'hui tout présenter une chronique
avec les lunettes de l'histoire
finalement le regard sur les artistes
autochtones de la scène les artistes - o
je pense que c'est important aussi parce
que quand on comprend l'histoire on
comprend la réalité doit absolument
absolument est donc la première chose
que j'ai envie de vous dire c'est que la
loi sur les indiens qui a été établie en
1876 déjà à partir de 1884 jusqu'en 1951
la loi sur les indiens offert un
amendement qui interdisait aux
autochtones de pratiquer leurs champs
leurs danses leur cérémonie chrétienne
oui sous peine de prison va aller de 2 à
6 à 6 mois
donc quand même donc si on les
retrouvait à chanter adam raga et will
croyant oui après tout on y va les
mettre en prison
oui donc évidemment une coupure
importante au niveau de la transmission
des chants et des danses notamment
de la musique donc des tambours bon de
tous les outils musicaux également donc
on se retrouve en 1951 et à ce moment là
la loi sur les indiens est à nouveau
amendé et là on permet aux autochtones
de pratiquer leurs champs leurs dents
mais ç'a pris du temps cancer du sein
bien sûr on parle de 70 ans mais oui
sinon 1951 mais on est à l'apogée des
pensionnats autochtones et là encore
évidemment la culture autochtone et les
uns nier qu'elle est réprimandé on veut
la cacher on veut faire passer le
top-ten on veut le faire accéder au
titre de citoyen et de blanville
assimilés oui donc là encore c'est pas
une période qui est très évidente dans
les années et vit damman bon à l'époque
des années 50 60
ce n'est pas tout les autochtones qui
était en réserve qui était en communauté
donc encore plusieurs autochtones
notamment québec les innu qui vivait
encore en territoire puisque plusieurs
réserves notamment sur la côte-nord ont
été créés dans les années 70 donc ça ça
fait en sorte que les choses ont pu
continuer à être transmises quand même
le les chansons la musique dans un
territoire où il n'y avait pas la police
ou les fonctionnaires du ministère des
affaires indiennes pourront vérifier une
été tranquille on est peut-être qu'elle
est pour ceux qui étaient déjà domicile
lien qui était déjà en réserve en
communauté mais on le faisait en
cachette on veut pas se le cacher c'est
pour ça qu'on a encore des chants mot
work aujourd'hui de la musique un mort
quand rossi wendat au tournant des
années 70 quelques communautés
autochtones vont miser sur le tourisme
comme outil de développement économique
c'est notamment le cas à odanak chez les
abénakis à wendat qui est dans ma
communauté et le tourisme et les
européens et qu'est ce que les européens
veulent voir ils veulent voir des
autochtones en action donc avec les
costumes avec les tambours avec macha et
donc là tranquillement on veut miser sur
la culture à nouveau mais c'est une
culture qui a été un peu émacié que une
cooper et tout fait oui et tout vingt
alors on va on voit un peu triché avons
veut s'inspirer de romance qui pourrait
qu'ils pouvaient avec les chants
traditionnels
oui pour recréer tous assez dense ces
chants leurs à la même époque aussi on
est dans un contexte socio politique
d'affirmation autochtone un peu partout
on veut se réapproprier une certaine
forme de culture c'est la naissance de
l'association des indiens du québec
l'ancêtre de l'assemblée des premières
nations du québec labrador au canada et
à la fraternité des indiens du canada
également
donc on va miser sur la culture comme un
outil d'affirmation et tranquillement
les années 80 vont être marquées par des
parois qui sont un peu différents des
parois d'aujourd'hui à l'époque les
parois s'étaient pas des compétitions de
danse étaient des artistes autochtones
qu'on présentait dans des grands
festivals dans les communautés
principalement bien sûr les allochtone
est invité je me souviens tout petit il
y avait plein de gens de leur et d'huile
de québec qui venait notamment owen
d'accueil il a hésité quand même à
odanak c'était la même chose qui
m'excite du fola alors on le voyait
c'est vraiment il y avait il y avait
quand même un côté oui un peu
folklorique dans les danses mais il y
avait des artistes contemporains quand
même à la guitare des jeunes autochtones
de commencer déjà à faire carrière et a
présenté leur oui mais les non
autochtones
venez voir ça comme un folklore oui un
peu on ne peut bien sûr oui ils sont
heureusement à changer et oui
heureusement ça a changé on retrouve pas
dans les années 80 ans que je n'ai pas
retrouvé dans mes recherches des traces
d'artistes autochtones dans les grands
festivals qui pouvait y avoir au québec
ça c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai
retrouvé bien sûr les artistes
autochtones se produisait mais davantage
dans leur commune dans leur communauté
alors vous avez vu mon doit passer tout
à l'heure c'est parce que j'ai invité
kathia rock à prendre place avec nos
bons jours katia bonjour katia vous êtes
auteur compositeur interprète
vous êtes aussi une comédienne mais là
c'est pour votre métier votre profession
d'auteur compositeur interprète que nous
vous avons invité isabelle nous parlait
de la présence des artistes autochtones
dans leur communauté
est-ce que c'est plus cela que vous êtes
présente non moi j'ai la chance a fait
24 ans que je fais ce métier l'homme
j'ai la chance de me promener un peu
partout à travers le québec ou en
outre-mer
mais c'est sûr que c'est très difficile
de
de vendre et de proposer nos musiques
dans des festivals québécois à cause de
la loi 101 pissos c'est moi je le répète
et je leur répète mme aujourd'hui c'est
l'fun parce qu'on peut l'on a accès à
aller au gala de l'adisq et une autre
musique ou être soutenu oui mais tout
souvient de la loi des indiens parce que
je ne pouvais pas chanter dans ma langue
donc je ne pouvais pas avoir un
producteur donc je ne pouvais pas avoir
un distributeur pour respecter les
normes les normes de l'industrie
musicale
je pouvais pas pas ça va dire non plus
qui achetait ne l'avait avait réussi à
l'époque mais à cause de la crise d'oka
ions et des fluides les ondes de oui
c'est ça aujourd'hui écoute mais les
festivals mois chaque année à partir du
mois de novembre jusqu'en février
ça c'est le booking on organise nous
notre tournée dans cette période là
pendant la map dont l'essai de se vendre
un peu partout de présenter nous offre
notre musique mais là n'est pas si j'ai
fait 67 festival j'ai proposé 61 et 67
estivale mais y en a deux qui m'ont
répondu on est d'accord mais avec le
gala de l'adisq
je pense que là maintenant c'est à part
le wapikoni mobile louis gagne à part la
musique nomade mais ya beaucoup
d'auteurs compositeurs interprètes qui
ont qu'ils sont sont des vieux de la
vieille de l'époque d'après cash
oui oui oui fake nous nous qui ont 20
ans d'expérience de simples tout on n'a
pas toutes le même
la même aide que la musique nomade offre
pour leurs jeunes vous avez expliqué
beaucoup de choses entre autres entre
autres la loi 101
pourquoi la loi 101 vous empêcher de
chanter dans votre langue grille oui me
m'empêchait de réaliser mon album
m'empêche est partout ça ne coupaient
pis c'est 65 % français que tu dois
chanter et que tu dois ou si tu
t'envoles du côté anglophone c'est 75%
donc ma langue devient mineur devient je
suis pas vendable présentable j'avoue en
tension des radios nous on peut pas fait
qu'on a eu certains artistes qui se sont
démarqués mais qui ont chanté en
français et en anglais
on y connait le ca pillon connaissent
amiens mais oui chantant qui aura oui on
pensait oui mais vous vous chantez en
français et en innu aujourd'hui j'ai
j'ai voulu me proposer comme auteur
compositeur interprète dans plusieurs
festivals dans les concours québécois
oui puis on me refusait aux mots refusé
parce que je chantais dans ma langue
mais il ya un festival au québec qui m'a
accepté et c'est la petite vallée je
remercie je payais la petite vallée
alcoa donne ce côté
merci beaucoup oui puis maudit cattiaux
qui vaut je te laisse chanter dans ta
langue mais on va faire un deal c'est 50
50 que j'ai dit ok à ce moment là je
suis allé chercher louise poirier que
l'auteur que j'admire énormément et avec
qui je travaille aussi
et là je travaille sur présentement un
album qui va sortir où je dois trouver
de l'argent pour la commercialisation
parce que ça c'est une autre étape
oui oui et puis
éventuellement l'album va sortir cette
année mais d'autres chantant faux mise
ok pour te dire que oui c'est ça je
m'étais légal maric je m'étais préparé
de chanter 50% dans mon album au lieu de
faire 60 et 100 m
je me suis dit je chantais 50% avec
louise où elle a vu que le gala de
l'adisq est sorti je peux pas retourner
en arrière mais je présente les oeuvres
bientôt le oui est ce que ces marchés
sur sur ces valeurs que d'avoir à
chanter aussi en français oui je suis
autochtone ja chante dans ma langue
j'écris dans ma langue vous respirez
dans votre langage un peu ça là où je
c'est différent oui oui là vous avez dit
ça amène des émotions aussi et c'est
normal mais oui vous avez dit que vous
avez approché 67 festivals et des
festivals autochtones et non autochtones
non juste des festivals non autochtone
et y en a deux qui ont répondu ouais et
les autres c'est quoi l'art et la
réponse qui fait jaillir reçu aucun
un avis de réception ou de retour de
courriel rien fait que c'est quand et
chanteuse puis tu proposes de vente en
voix inquiètes ou inquiètes de ce
spectacle qu'est ce que tu présentes
dans nos spectacles
oui c'est quoi ta bio ta démarche est
tout les trucs avec des photos d'eux et
de chanteuse wipikit t'envoie s'habitue
leur propose dans l'univers at what i
puis c'est triste que j'étais allé voir
la musique nomade que j'avais dit là
j'ai besoin des deux parce que moi tout
seul je viens vous nager à contre
courant vous écoutez moi mais ces essais
j'ai l'impression de nager à contre
courant depuis une vingtaine d'années oh
oui c'était puisaye ce je suis et je
suis fatigué oui je suis fatigué puis
c'est mon premier album
en 24 ans le livre je voulais juste mais
tous ne passent à radio piqueur que
jouent les gens et la vie un pull alors
on va revenir aux années 80 vous en avez
parlé isabelle les années 80 ça a été un
tournant un tournant évidemment qui a
mal fini avec les débuts des années 90
mais parlons des années 80 oui quand
même donc je le mentionnais certains pas
voit surtout dans les communautés au
canada anglais et aux bons offices et
mamies qui est une artiste chanteuse
musicienne cris de la saskatchewan qui
entre autres va passer à ses amis streep
j'ai passé mon sens oui mais elle
faisait la chronique musicale à ses amis
suez et ça ça lui ouvert énormément de
portes notamment au canada donc elle
fait un grand détour par les états unis
pour se faire connaître notamment et
elle est le gagner un grammy un golden
globe et un oscar pour sa chanson if we
belong de joe cocker c'est elle qui
avait fait la musique de cette chanson
là donc elle une reconnaissance
oui et ça ça ouvert plusieurs portes au
canada anglais maintenant si on revient
ici au québec on le mentionnait mise à
l'heure vers la fin des années 80
kashtin va faire son chemin et il veut
fracassé tous les records oui on se
plusieurs chansons je me souviens
j'étais enfin mais numéro un
tout le monde les québécois chantait
cache t il y avait à la main
mais pâques aussi séduit bernard
médaillé molinari que vous connaissez
peut-être il y avait alanis obomsawin
aussi avec son album boucherie dit
également donc tranquillement y avait un
essor à la fin des années 80 et on
sentait que les artistes autochtones
avaient leur place oui dans le québec
arrive la crise d'oka en 1990 tout le
monde mélange un peu tout et là les
radios 16 de jouer les chansons des
chanteurs autochtone la tôle
on leur interdit le jour on ajuste cessé
de voir que tu es boycotter complètement
con complément alors là il ya un grand
moment où on n'existe plus sur la scène
artistique québécoise
on se retrouve à la fin des années 90
avec laurent voilà qui n'avait jamais
cessé sa carrière est là qui se retrouve
comme artiste solo et qu'il ya quand
même un certain succès on évite quand
même les danseurs autochtone dans les
événements commémoratifs notamment la
fête du 1er juillet la fin du canada on
le voit encore à la fin des années 90
mais on dirait qu'on ne plus la parole
on dirait qu'on est au niveau de la
représentation est ce qu'à ce moment-là
il chante en français ou dans leur
langue
il se permet de chanter dans leur langue
à ce moment là mais en fait les danseurs
ils vont être accompagnés d'un chien au
tambour non la langue donc wendat
wakeboard et florent je sais qu'il fait
des duos notamment avec éric lapointe
donc un peu en français un choeur nous
et donc
peut-être qu'à ça serait plus en mesure
de répondre à ça maintenant les choses
ont changé avec l'arrivée de elisapie de
sam yann samuell notamment en 2007 avec
son premier album vraiment va ouvrir les
portes avec ces mots ou les mots un peu
militant es tu là
les charmants bien sûr donc tout le
monde veut l'entendre il ya quelque
chose de nouveau qui arrive ils risquent
d'appui en eux en même temps qu'ils en
2004 quand même avait fait un album avec
time sommes donc en duo mais qui en 2009
au son premier album solo on connaît un
énorme succès quand même au québec et le
vont s'ensuivre
chaoui et natasha khan ap fontaine aussi
qui va prendre place à plusieurs
festivals je me souviens de la fête de
la saint jean baptiste à montréal où
elle était porte parole
donc ça c'est quand même bien sûr sur
mots parfois lambeaux willy à le faire
un truc avec émile procès oui et donc et
et donc il ya 400 également que j'ai vu
dans plusieurs événements corporatifs
des événements un peu partout et
dernièrement maillot matthew qu'on
entend à la radio qui est un artiste y
noue également donc en cinq ans même un
nouveau new york qui sont qui sont
ouvertes oui on espère qu'elle ne se
refermeront pas d'ailleurs là-dessus
j'ai vu dans une toute petite salle dans
un centre culturel à côté de chez moi
cet hiver on était comme 25 dans la
salle puis les gens vraiment été au
moins on sait qui lui faisait mais
pourquoi connais pas plus brillé pas sur
une plus grande scène que ça et qui
débute
il commence qui est qu'avec une belle
maison des gens septième ciel louis saha
qui s'est agrandie de rentrer comme ça
où tout est oui et puis il ya aussi
annoncé charles witt que j'ai vu dans le
centre culturel et matthew je n'ai vu il
était lui dans une maison de la culture
avec laura nicoué les deux sur la scène
là aussi les gens étaient vraiment
contente ça a été comme l'ovation à la
fois que je me faisais mais pourquoi mes
mates ou ivato franco m oui j'ai vu ça
le 20 juin il sera sur une scène
extérieure offrant moa donc ça c'est une
bonne chose
katia les francos pour vous est ce que
c'est quelque chose d'envisageable
quelque chose dont vous rêvez que vous
aimeriez jouer j'ai travaillé sur un
projet qui s'appelait que ça qui
s'appelle toujours mahmoud tonnes qui
est un rassemblement où j'ai invitait
aux artistes aux auteurs compositeurs
interprètes des onze nations pour faire
entendre les langues autochtones au
québec
et j'ai évité aux auteurs compositeurs
québécois qui avait une autre langue que
le français
via oui mais malraux s j'avais lynda
thalie avec sept autres des univers qui
viennent enrichir les la rencontre et
les compositions et ce album love
ressortir aussi bientôt à la que j'ai
été approché par les francos j'ai dû
tout reporté parce qu'on travaille sur
l'album présentement mais au moins il ya
eu une invitation
oui oui il ya eu un intérêt avec
monsieur sony et où il est on arrivé oui
ce sont ni m'invitait écrivent vous êtes
comédienne aussi est ce que est ce que
c'est ce qui vous aide aussi à vous
faire connaître comme comme interprète
comme auteure compositrice interprète ou
sa part rapport écoute mon premier
métier c'est vraiment auteur compositeur
interprète je suis une chanteuse georges
mas conflit je m'assume totalement
comédienne j'ai tombé dedans ça
m'attirait
j'ai rentré pendant j'ai travaillé
pendant douze ans avec la compagnie
théâtre on dit non oui qui m'ont
vraiment mis au monde et un temps
comédienne pour aller chercher tout les
sens et comment travailler tout les
niveaux de jeu les techniques de jeu
c'est une compagnie autochtone vous et
quand même le mentionner oui ce qu'elle
a remis à la ligue qui vous a fait
confiance qui vous a donné une plainte
oui oui qui m'a écouté qui m'a donné une
place et écoute je bénis en inox et je
souhaite que tous les jeunes autochtones
a hélas cette chance-là dos à cette
chance de travailler avec nous et si oui
durant et catherine jean cas je suis
comédienne je travaille beaucoup tant au
niveau à la télévision que dans les
longs métrages et où théâtre aussi que
j'avais délaissé les dernières années
cette année je travaille sur trois
pièces dans des univers complètement
différents et là c'est pas seulement des
comptines hoc
non parce qu'on dit non que vous a donné
cette première chance et ensuite on a
voulu le talent que vous aviez manqué
lentement j'ai accepté un contrat avec
hôtel motel pour présenter une oeuvre
c'est un gars qui est fait dans les
communautés autochtones et qui aura
marre c'est toutes les histoires des ex
pensionnaires
cette histoire triste
je joue toujours c'est assez à mon goût
c'est tout le ca ca de l'histoire
autochtone oui ok puis nous on joue moi
je joue j'interprète suspects six femmes
qui se confient qu'ils partagent leur
univers
c'est très dur écoute ça m'a amené très
loin et j'ai dû
jeudi consulter ce test je dis là encore
avec sa wii chercher profonde avec j
accepte un autre contre eux qui est une
pièce pour les enfants qui s'appelle
ceux qui rêvent et c'est nathalie picard
wendat qui a écrit la pièce en
collaboration avec françois racine et on
présente cette pièce là cet automne et
j'ai passé une autre audition pour
travailler et le je fais ma grande
entrée après vingt ans à la place des
arts et je suis extrêmement fier du nez
je peux me dire hélas et ont donc en
théâtre au théâtre aussi ça c'est tout
des trois pièces de théâtre où il a
lancé oui puis là je travaille avec
rené richard cyr à la mise en scène avec
une coupelle de bale bruce chen s'est
vraiment fait d'enfants heureusement que
vous avez aussi cet autre talent qui lui
permet de compléter votre talent de
chanteuse mais après je rentre et n'en
compte aussi fait que j'ai dit il ya des
années ça marche beaucoup en musique et
je fais que de la musique pendant un été
oui parfois si c'est le théâtre parfois
cédé long métrage oui parfois c'est mon
côté comme eden est là cet été je me
promène en tant que chanteuse et en tant
que compte jouer
actuellement je l'écris sur ma feuille
que je vois que les pas fait vous êtes
originaire de quelle communauté
malioténam vous êtes de madiot d'accord
ok alors si vous aviez été d'une
communauté beaucoup plus haute mettons
en côte nord sur la basse côte nord
est ce que ça aurait été aussi pas
facile mais est ce que ça aurait été
plus difficile d'en sortir pour vous
faire connaître en tant qu'artiste mais
parce que maillot il s'est tout à une
pépinière
on envoie grenoble je ne pouvais pas moi
je savais qu'à cinq ans j'allais partir
ailleurs
puis à 11 ans j'ai fait venir j'ai
découvert un film qui a changé ma vie et
c'était l'école le faith film sur
facebook music le théâtre une école
montréalaise fait pour les artistes
présents j'ai découvert ce qui fait que
j'ai fait venir plein de trucs et j'ai
présenté l'idée à ma mère qui m'a mère
m'a dit mais doit rester aux mains je
m'attendais à une tante à montréal
peut-être qu on va pouvoir me prendre
puis je vais voyager comme ça oui
non non non pas d'attenté fait le jeu
dur qui bon père tual est resté chez les
bonnes soeurs mais moi je ne comprenais
pas parce que c'était tabou à l'époque
oui ami 14 ans j'ai écrit une lettre à
mon conseil de bande parce qu'on est
géré par notre conseil ou jeudi écoutez
je suis une artiste et je dois partir à
montréal dans cette école et je dois
me mettre au monde oui oui ils ont
accepté de payer mais ma formation et de
payer aussi mon transport mon
appartement ma base métro où ma bouffe
aidante et visionnaire dès que j'ai tout
refait tenir les acteurs et j'avais été
accepté à l'école et j'ai dit à ma mère
voilà je me mange par mais maintenant je
sais où j'ai un appartement mais qui
vaut pays''
le conseil de bande avec le jeu pouvait
oui donné à 14 ans fait qu'amener mario
par sa fille je te laisse entre les
mains de dieu et depuis ce temps là je
suis à montréal mais j'ai besoin de
retourner chez nous parce que j'ai
besoin de m'ancrer de me retrouver de de
rencontrer des aînés de m'asseoir de
dormir de de toucher 2 août
j'ai besoin de vous parce que c'est ma
source d'inspiration et c'est tout
mon père oui donc ma démarcation en tant
qu'artiste alors on parlait de la
distance et ça nous amène jusqu'au
jusqu'au nunavik avec mathis parce qu'on
sait la culture inouk là elle est
reconnue pour son foisonnement
artistique on la voit dans tous les
domaines d'ailleurs ce soit de la
musique sculpture chants de gorge etc -
la danse et là je dis nunavik mais c'est
nunavut en fait l'article de alors oui
c'est le nord par contre il ya les
artistes inuit qui n'ont pas la vie
facile c'est pas évident pour eux de se
faire connaître beaucoup vers une autre
réalité
oui je pense que percer comme artiste
émergence commence in-stat une carrière
musicale peu importe où on réside c'est
déjà quelque chose de difficile en plein
choc est difficile mais les obstacles
auxquels vont se heurter des les les
inuit dans le nord du canada où nous
n'avons tout nunavik sont assez
différents de des obstacles auxquels se
heurtent les artistes émergents du sud
qui sont souvent en fait c'est des
enjeux qui sont souvent des acquis dans
le sud et auquel on pense pas et l'on
parle de l'ajustement la barrière
géographique il ya toutes sortes de
choses qui font que
que c'est d'autant plus difficile pour
les artistes de commencer une carrière
dans le nord et je pense avant tout au
manque d'infrastructures pour pouvoir
performer sur une scène hay le nunavut
c'est le seul territoire parmi les
provinces et territoires du pays s'il
cela pas disposer d'un centre culturel
d'une salle de spectacle proprement
parler pour les arts de la scène aux
gars de la fin pour juste pour la
musique pour le théâtre et chez terra
oui donc juste le fait de ne pas pouvoir
jouer performer devant un public que je
pense que c'est probablement vous le
savez comme ça qu'on se construit aussi
en tant qu'artiste mais juste ça c'est
un frein important et ensuite le coût
élevé des déplacements en cédant au
nunavut normalement notamment il n'y a
pas de route qui relie les communautés
les assurés par roselyne avec la même
chose ça se fait par avion donc c'est
non seulement se déplacer soi-même et
transporter l'équipement les instruments
de musique extrêmement coûteux oui
seule la question du coût des
déplacements c'est un double obstacle à
la fois pour les pour les artistes
partout mais ni si oui visiblement tu
sais mais c'est aussi dans le nord c'est
aussi un obstacle pour les festivals
parce que faire venir des artistes qui
viennent de différentes communautés de
différentes régions c'est extrêmement
cher donc c'est seul est à la fois pour
les festivals qui veulent promouvoir la
la la scène régionale mais aussi pour
les artistes qui veulent se faire
connaître
oui ça brûle donc ces deux grands enjeux
mais ensuite il ya la question des
déformations protégeait pas d'université
au nunavut ul collège de l'article cas
louit mais pas de formation qui est
destiné à auchan par exemple ou à la
musique
donc il faut il faut sortir de sa
communauté il faut avoir les sous pour
le faire et puis donc ça c'est un frein
important
ensuite la question c'est des agents est
représenté par un agent oui on oublie
oui c'est ouais et pas de critique
musical non plus donc on voit quand même
cccc il ya beaucoup de défis beaucoup de
défis et la question vous l'avez dit
elle revient évidemment aussi du côté
des inuits parce que se faire connaître
est ce qu est ce que finalement il ya un
choix à faire il ya beaucoup d'artistes
qui vont décider de chanter en anglais
parce que il semble qu'ils sont pas
compris par des artistes par des débats
publics ailleurs au canada puis c'est
surtout la question de la langue a bien
souvent
une problématique qui apparaît souvent
quand l'artiste veut sortir de sa région
parce que dans par exemple nunavut ya
plusieurs dialectes mais généralement
les artistes vont être comprimées quand
ils sortent de leur territoire c'est là
où les jambes le public méconnaît
complètement la langue la langue inouk
donc c'est là où il ya un choix qui
s'impose puis au contraire il y en a
d'autres qui vont choisir justement de
continuer à chanter dans leur dialecte
pour plus de raison par fierté par comme
manière de se réapproprier aussi son
identité aussi parce préoccupation pour
la survie de la l'allant qui nous donc
est une sorte des raisons qui fait que
je pense qu un déchirement est ce que je
fais la moitié de mon album masqué
combien j'ai combien de chansons que je
compose en anglais ou un oui donc je
pense qu'il ya un choix il ya un choix
un peu déchirage ans je fais tout de
suite une parenthèse hors contexte vous
avez dit la langue inouk alors on va
tout de suite mettre une chose au clair
le service linguistique de radio canada
a finalement accepté de parler d'un
ebook et des inuits alors vous allez
voir ça dans notre conversation et dans
nos textes un nid nook des inuit
on ne conjugue pas inouïe d'hp à deux
pas de s i hate et en symboles revoilà
donc je ferme la parenthèse on pourrait
parler des alternatives maintenant que
lilian nord il y en a pas parce que bon
malgré tous ces obstacles à je veux dire
ça peut arrêter tout le monde quand
leurs résidents heureusement
heureusement il ya des artistes
émergents qui ont usé de leur créativité
pour faire connaître leur composition
vous y pensez sûrement le numérique
numerama mais je sais pas comment vous
faites ça vous a servi
ben moi ça m'a servi parce que justement
c'est le meilleur moyen âge l'homme et
garçons me dis ok moment-là je n'arrête
pas de montrer des vidéos où la foudre
est en face des nouvelles mélodies
oui j'ai fait comme mais éventuellement
facebook brand sa guitare et revenir à
la source
oui
ça fonctionne très bien et moi
j'encourage les jeunes des régions
éloignées de s'asseoir et de regarder la
caméra est de 2 raconte et raconte moi
ton histoire
mais la suisse a déjà un an
ouais on demande oui tout le monde mais
j'ai un jeune auteur compositeur que je
suis il ya à peu près dix ans puis
formidable
écoute je le suis le régulièrement j'ai
une fois de temps en temps je vois les
écrire un petit quelque chose vient d'où
il vient de maingain ah oui il me
regarde vite
oui descoings et puis bon on mettra le
lien sur facebook en sortant jade et
nous dirons valeur-ajoutée on veut le
connaître ok alors mettez donc voilà les
améliorer je pense que c'est il est beau
instagram
ensuite je l'aimais les plateformes où
ces de distribution audio comme beenkens
son talent qui sont même manière de
télécharger le contenu si on a une bonne
connexion internet parce que c'est un
autre enjeu
oui ni camry no 6 qui est l'initiative
de musique ne maquille été lancée sur
est ce que vous faites partie vous êtes
sur la liste des artistes dominique
amorim ok je suis pour des raisons
période monsieur ça a donné comme ça
parce que je travaille beaucoup
d'emplois et d'autres afin dé fois que
c'est vous avez vos régions dans mes
horaires d'accord je suis assez mais
c'est une belle plateforme de vente est
de plus en plus du côté des inuit je
vous dirais que c'est encore un peu
embryonnaire il ya deux gros kwanten
tango oui
si line rice qui mélange musique
électronique et chants de gorge
donc c'est les deux pour le moment ils
sont assez connus mais peut-être
éventuellement se rassurent le voir s'il
ya d'autres
ouais mais moi j'en suis pas mal aussi
la baule il y en a de plus en plus des
inouk des inuit qui commence des jeunes
jeunes filles qui commencent vraiment à
découvrir mon univers assez formidable
oui ça commence à venir de partout
j'espère que mon clair que nous en
parlera parce que trois zones tango etc
la noise on peut les découvrir sur sous
la chronique de de monclar qui s'appelle
mama ou une musique sur nos titres j'en
profite pour faire un peu de publicité à
la maintenant il ya aussi les festivals
quand même du côté des inuit ya qu'elle
en a il y en a actuellement oui y'a pas
que le numérique finalement les
festivals justement on est un peu à
l'orée d'une période de festival dans le
nord
mais le festival lez'arts aliens italien
night of ce festival qui lui a été
allouée du 28 juin au 1er juillet
baroche dans quelques jouets oui et
c'est un gros festival 5000 personnes
qui sont attendues
ça fait plusieurs années que je me oui
lundi via j'ose penser à son prochain
cauchemar aux joies coup sérieux à coude
droit qui c'est c'est plutôt moi d'où
s'échappaient arcadiens oui il y en a un
autre que je donne tout mais la cire
comme paulin aussi dans les
anouk là c'est vraiment génial celui là
aussi et ça c'est bien parce qu'on prend
aussi les artistes du sud pour les faire
découvrir au nord il ya un peu de tout
mais du côté dalian être cette année
habituellement ils ont toujours un thème
qui guident un peu le festival cette
année
les organisatrices ont décidé qu'il y
aura pas de thème et qui ont leur
sélection d'artistes serait presque 100%
autochtone donc il ya désigné mais il ya
aussi des artistes autochtones qui
viennent de différentes régions du
canada puis là c'est un peu ce qu'ils
voulaient mettre de l'avant cette année
là qu il ya des artistes des tout jeunes
artistes dans la vingtaine y en a des
plus établis va y avoir du mentorat
justement avec queen comme tango donc
c'est à surveiller je prépare d'ailleurs
un petit texte l'ue la semaine prochaine
à dessus qui se regarde sur l'ortie
exact oui sinon donc un arctique par
l'onss clément la prononciation à recul
gamme qui est au mois d'août à coups de
joie qu est sinon là donc ça fait un
bond qui existent aux autres quand même
un truc excellent année puis non
je connaissais pas je connaissais pas ce
festival s'il m'en approche c'est parce
qu'ils ont besoin de mes vidéos surfer
actuellement de bataille
oui mais c'est un beau tremplin ouais
ouais ça fait reconnaît de jouer devant
un public d'apprendre à interagir avec
une foule c'est pour ça que l'oeil il
insiste beaucoup cette année sur le
mentorat justement pour comment est ce
qu on perfectionne ses chansons comment
est-ce qu'on intéresse justement avec
des spectateurs puis belle manière de
son mari mais
et pas juste de performer et puis
l'autre festival le pain le pagne fest
panier retourne le festival de paniers
retourne sur l'île de baffin nunavut
celui là au lieu du 9 au 12 août
prochain et donc tout a lieu cet été
donc ça c'est du côté des festivals et
le numérique sinon d'autres initiatives
il y en a aussi tout à l'heure je disais
qu'il n'y avait pas de 200 d'information
qui avait pas de scène pour pouvoir
performer ça risque peut-être changer
sous peu au nunavut
je sais pas si vous connaissez
l'organisme à but non lucratif cariat
voûte dont j'ai parlé quelques semaines
dans le fonds us travaille depuis
plusieurs années sur la création de
grands ensembles d or de la scène et il
commence la construction au mois de
juillet à iqaluit et d'un habitué le 4g
krob ça va être un centre un bâtiment
qui va être destinés aux arts de la
scène mais ce n'est pas fermée ils vont
être offert des formations puis
où les gens vont pouvoir gris performer
c'est très bien ça fait du bien
d'entendre ce genre d'initiative du
québec je suis en train de monter ce
genre de projet là aussi pour les
laurentides dans les laurentides
bonjour ashton pour les autochtones
c'est bien mais toujours vraie formation
mais aussi rassembler commencé à
acheminer en sol québécois oui oui oui
old town toujours avec les deux nations
avec moi je voyage beaucoup dans l'ouest
à winnipeg qui est le cas central des
musiques autochtone de tout ce qui est
art autochtone et ils sont très avancées
là bas et j'ai la chance de parler
beaucoup avec alinghi aux qui lui est
comme le l'espèce de grands manitous
chef d'orchestre qui organise plein
plein de trucs sur l'industrie musicale
il fait venir des auteurs thème d'un peu
partout à travers le canada et le québec
pour justement les leur donner un coup
de main de dans l'est encore plus c'est
que je disais moi je m'en sers comme toi
au québec parce qu'au québec qui a rien
qui ce passe vite et que tu as des plus
que moi parce que tu fais beaucoup plus
de choses et tout ça tout ça avec un
agent ou avec 100 agents écoute janvier
dans une agence de la wii qui touche mon
côté comédienne oui c'est cela oui si
j'avais pas diane riel dans ma ville ça
fait une dizaine d'années que je t'avais
qu'elle si j'avais pas diane real serait
pas là où je suis en ce moment
ok mais du côté du travail de comedia
j'ai travaillé comme événement oui mais
c'est elle qui me présente devant kiki
qui argumentent tout le monde piqué en
musique ça prendrait pas ça aussi ça
m'apprendra hunt blue j'en ai une qui
m'a approché dernièrement fait qd c'est
en train de se placer au dessus mais ce
ne sont pas tous les artistes
autochtones qui est réussi mais voir un
oui la dalle
oui je gêne parce que je fais je vois
toujours continuer à faire ce que je
fais mais mon groupe dada j'ai trouvé un
malin plaisir à organiser arras
bhl et les gens semblent oui je ne sais
pas comment expliquer cela mais je
m'envole la joie oui je vais sortir mon
album oui je vais me promener quand même
jour choisir maisé barie oui oui mais je
veux rester à la maison et éviter et il
rassemble et offrir ce que moi je suis
allé chercher tout seul parce que je
suis autodidacte et je veux j'ai
toujours dit je me suis surpris à chaque
année qu'est ce que je veux je m'envoie
au quand comment pourquoi vicky wifek
j'ai atteint mes objectifs comme ça mais
un jeune sortir un jeune d'une
communauté éloignée de le faire venir en
ville il ya déjà un gros crash mais
wifaq si je la mets l'amour puis je le
présente puis que l'on commence à petit
je le sais je le travaille je je l'aï
aidé à devenir une fleur c'est ce que
révèle je crée un champ alors matiz vous
nous parliez des festivals chez les
inuit l'on va parler des festivals chez
les premières nations
oui parce qu'il en a évidemment
plusieurs dans le sud mais il
heureusement il n'y a pas juste des
festivals pour les autochtones ya aussi
les grands festivals où de plus en plus
d'autochtones vont heureusement d'abord
les festivals autochtones y en a
plusieurs pistes ça commence oui on a
plusieurs mais en fait ça commence
toujours mais avec le festival manitou
habits à winnipeg essayé dans le cadre
de ce festival doc on veut retrouver les
djinns music awards où l'on me convient
on connaît davantage donc c'est un
rassemblement de 4,5 jours à chaque
année est vraiment c'est que c'est quand
même assez gros comme le woodstock des
autochtones en quelque sorte maintenant
à travers les parois qu'il ya un peu
partout dans les communautés souvent pas
toujours mais souvent il va y avoir un
volet spectacle non présentation
d'artistes autochtones c'est le cas à
wendake et c'est le cas à odanak
notamment donc il certain paoua qui vont
aussi avoir un volet où les artistes
vont se présenter cette année à luanda
qui sait le
dj crise cris qui fait de la musique
électronique qui va être sur scène le 29
juin
samia est déjà allé quelques années donc
dépendamment des années ils vont la
formule vont un peu changé dans le jour
on a le pas au traditionnel avec les
concours de danse et au soir on va avoir
un événement plutôt musique à laquelle
qui veut présenter des artistes
autochtones donc ça c'est un délit
odanak aussi fonctionne de cette manière
là bien sûr il ya le festival très
connus inoni goût à mal et ce chaque
année cette année c'est du 1er au 4 ou
2019 j'ai tenté de regarder la
programmation n'est pas encore sorti le
moment veuillez laisser un court message
mais kim s'est organisé la semaine
passée au tournoi pour amasser des fonds
de golf puis là cette semaine qu il
commence à créer la leur
kim boucher martin oui crime de chez
matt and kim labarre 6 oui et le
directeur du festival qui a pris la
place en fait du frère de l'auteur
original
oui oui donc un gros festival il ya
aussi bien sûr à montréal le festival
présence autochtone oui on connaît donc
cette année c'est du 6 au 14 août et là
encore la programmation tarder à se
faire connaître car je sais pas quand on
regarde son honneur mais non mais mais
en fait ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'au moins on sait que jérémy dos
turquie a quand même gagné un juno cette
année et le prix polaris l'an passé il
va être le 3 juillet au club soda dans
le cadre du festival de jazz vive
c'est vrai mike paul qui est un artiste
innu de masse teillage qui a été en
nomination pour les génisses music
awards va être au festival de
l'outaouais en fête le 21 juin prochain
elisapie elle est en tournée un peu
partout présentement ou à partir de la
semaine prochaine est en tournée dans
l'ouest canadien
tel montant de 21 jeunes amis l'allemand
avait oui et bombay samian bien sûr à
compter de septembre je l'avais
mentionné je sais pas s'il fait des
festivals cet été mais entre tout ça est
à surveiller
voilà et puis je le disais il ya matthew
qui va être aux francos le 20 juin à 19h
sur une scène extérieure à nico est
aussi que s'en va ou aux francos je sais
pas la même couleur à nicolet elle est
très bonne à surveiller alors faut oui
oui absolument
ok je pense qu'on a fait le tour c'est
vraiment formidable katia merci d'être
venu nous parler de vos nombreux projets
on va vous suivre de très près sur tout
cet album qui devrait sortir quand ben
je cherche des sous là je suis dans la
recherche de sous ou justement pour
sortir la bonne chance merci espère que
ça va marcher
oui merci à toutes les trois encore une
fois toutes les deux et merci katia de
votre présence aujourd'hui mais la
semaine prochaine nous avons une
émission spéciale 21 juin c'est la
journée nationale des peuples
autochtones nous aurons une émission
spéciale nous serons dans vieux montréal
en extérieur s'il ne pleut pas ou à
l'intérieur de l'espace culturel à shaw
can s'il pleut mais et nous allons faire
une émission spéciale sur les langues
autochtones vous allez voir nous or nous
allons découvrir plusieurs langues
autochtones avec des invités vraiment
intéressant donc c'est un rendez vous
vendredi prochain à 12h15 merci au
revoir